digamos que quiero multiplicar 3.1 o
tres y un décimo por 2.4 que también lo
podemos describir como 2 y 4 decimos
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
y una vez más les daré una pista trata
de expresar esto como a fracciones hay
un par de formas para expresar esto como
fracciones pueden expresar esto como
tres y un décimo por dos y cuatro
décimos
ahora aquí tenemos números mixtos y no
hay una manera sencilla para
multiplicarlos es más fácil si los
escribimos como lo que se conoce como
fracciones impropias pero que
esencialmente no estén escritas como
números mixtos así que 3 es lo mismo que
30 decimos entonces 30 décimos más un
décimo esto es 31 décimos por todos es
lo mismo que 20 décimos entonces 20
décimos más 4 es igual a 24 décimos o 24
sobre 10 y espero que le encuentren
sentido a esto que 3.1 este 3 que
tenemos aquí es igual a 30 decimos
y este es un décimo
y en total tenemos 31 décimos y de la
misma manera este 2 es igual a 20
decimos más 4 decimos nos dan estos 24
décimos y ahora podemos multiplicarlos
entonces esto nos va a dar los
denominadores son más sencillos 10 por
10 es igual a 100 y luego 31 por 24 lo
podemos multiplicar de la forma
tradicional en la que acostumbramos a
multiplicar números de dos dígitos 31
por 24 es igual a 4 por 1 es 4 4 por 3
es 12
ahora vamos a multiplicar en la posición
de las decenas así que vamos a poner un
cero aquí entonces 2 por 1 es 2 en
realidad estamos diciendo 20 por 1 es
igual a 20 pero ya saben la idea 2 por 1
es 22 por 36 en realidad 600 porque
estamos multiplicando 20 por 30 pero
estoy siguiendo el método estándar para
la multiplicación y luego sumamos esto y
nos da 4 47
así que cuando multiplicamos estos dos
números en el numerador nos da a 744
centésimos que también podemos expresar
como setecientos centésimos más 44
centésimos y 700 centésimas es igual a 7
esto es 7 más 44 centésimas que también
podemos escribir como punto 44 y el
resultado es 7 y 44 centésimos y
terminamos tal vez se han dado cuenta de
un patrón si simplemente multiplican 31
por 24 obtienen 744 y noten esto tengo 1
y 2 dígitos después del punto fíjense
tengo 1 y 2 dígitos después del punto y
piensen si esto va a funcionar siempre
piensen porque esto debería funcionar si
simplemente multiplican los números como
si no tuvieran decimales obtendrían 744
y luego pueden decir tengo 2 números
después del punto así que mi producto va
a tener
números después del punto porque
funciona o siempre funciona y cómo se
relaciona eso con lo que hicimos aquí de
convertir estos números en fracciones
impropias y luego en multiplicar las de
esta manera